well after a week of foreign policy the
president turning is focused
domestically trying to get
pharmaceutical prices down how to do
that is the real question drug pricing
goals increase competition in the drug
markets you heard him there give
Medicare Part D plans better tools to
negotiate on behalf of senior citizens
develop new incentives for drug
manufacturers develop options to lower
patient's out-of-pocket spending you've
got these prescription drugs in the u.s.
18,000 plus approved and available and
this number 328 billion dollars spent on
drugs forty-nine percent of Americans
have used a prescription drug in the
last 30 days amazing stats as you go
down the line there let's start there
and bring in our panel Steve Hays
editor-in-chief of the Weekly Standard
Karen Tumulty opinion writer for The
Washington Post I'm Molly Hemingway
senior editor at the Ferrell Federalist
Karen ambitious for the President to go
down this road we've seen other
administrations try to do it what about
this well he did however back off of his
campaign promise which was to have
Medicare negotiate directly with the
pharmaceutical country companies for
prices that was the howitzer of all of
this and he decided not to fire it and
so it's significant that after this was
announced the stock prices as the
pharmaceutical companies actually went
up yeah and so speaking of
pharmaceutical companies part of this
the HHS secretary said you had to adjust
what's in ads ticketless think about all
the time that everybody spends watching
drug company ads on TV and how much
information companies are required to
put in them if we want to have a real
market for drugs why not have them
disclose their prices in the ads too so
basically the HHS secretary is saying
transparency on pricing for drug
companies yeah but to do that you have
to enact new regulations when I think a
lot of the rest of the plan was about
deregulating or streamlining how these
drugs make it to marketplace to the
point about the stock market showing
that there wasn't just the drug
companies but also the pharmacy benefit
managers their stocks also went up I
think that what was really interesting
about the plan was that it does get more
generics into the marketplace that's
really key that's key for lowering the
prices and it's the most substantial
thing the rest seems to be more about
like sharing among the different groups
who gets to get all this money so it's
also true if you're gonna pass something
like this you need Democratic support
it's going to be less robust then it was
talked about but it I think it does have
a chance to get pretty big Democrat
there are some levers though at HHS that
they can do outside of of Congress sure
a lot of power there ya know HHS has a
lot of power and that's what that's why
you know the president's announcements
the announcements are necessarily broad
you listed the goals a lot will depend
on how they roll it out and what the
actual details look like but I think I
mean on the matter of recruiting
Democrats I mean it seems to me that
what the president did was take a step
away as Karen points out from his
campaign rhetoric this is a less
populist plan it's something that more
in line with traditional Republican
President might offer and I think that
will make it less attractive to
Democrats in Congress if this in fact is
has a big push forward because it's not
as it's not as government centric all
right let's turn to the Russian
investigation well specifically the the
Cohen part Michael Cohen the president's
attorney has this contract with AT&T we
learned that they hired them January
through December a one-year contract
$50,000 per month
limited to providing consulting and
advisory services apparently tied to the
Time Warner deal the head of AT&T
Randall Stephenson coming out telling
employees it was a big mistake yeah and
he was the second CEO to apologize for
having hired Michael Cohen the other
being the head of Novartis the drug
company it's not that any of this is
illegal in fact it's it's very much
business as usual in Washington it's
just it's the influence industry is
there it's just new players in it but it
is unseemly and it does these are the
kind things are the kind of deals that
corporations just hate to have put out
in the open sea if then they shouldn't
do them honestly I mean if they don't
want to be exposed don't do it look this
cuts against they or they are living in
the source they have they want to make
their best arguments that they can pay
somebody to make the rest
it's for them they'll do that this cuts
against the heart of President Trump's
campaign message he was going to drain
the swamp this is the swamp it's the
swamp only swampy and I think that's why
this is a potential political problem
for the president for the people who
supported the president because they
thought well I'm sick of Washington DC I
don't like the way that Washington
operates everybody's scratching
everybody's backs it's payoffs here it's
kickbacks there that's basically what
this is let's start I want to rewind it
started with a lot of a lot of focus on
the Russian oligarch tied to one of the
companies he's denied that the companies
denied that he was funding it for the
money that made it to Cohen we don't
know what Muller has but what about
where that Russia part of it stands and
what we know about it well first off I
think it's worth remembering that the
reason why this is even being discussed
is because there was a leak by
government officials of insensitive
information I don't know if that came
from the special counsel someone at the
Treasury Department somewhere else
that's a criminal leak it's really
inappropriate and there's been a big
problem with leaks coming from various
investigations and it should be taken
seriously and the problem with these
amounts really is that the size and
scope of government is so big and if you
want to drain the swamp you have to deal
with the size and scope of government as
long as it's this big people are going
to play this game and it's not and the
way that everyone's acting like totally
surprised that this is happening it's a
little bit of silly naivete as for the
trying to link this to the Russia
investigation I think it's interesting
that this attorney avenatti was trying
to link it to Russia that suggests that
this information is part of this larger
message about Russia I don't think that
case was actually made well except that
Russia is a country in the in the world
that has global interests and they might
have distant ties to some of these
companies that are funding what about
the núñez part and what they are not
getting at a DOJ as of yet yeah well at
this point it's been interesting that
the the White House has sided with in
the Department of Justice had on the
same side of this one we haven't seen
them in that that position that often so
the hill is going to continue to push
the Republicans on the hill are going to
continue to push for this source to be
revealed and the question really I think
it's going to be whether you know once
president understands that this source
is also somebody who has been
cooperating with the Muller
investigation whether we're going to
continue to see this united front and I
think that's what was so interesting
about this Department of Justice leaked
to the Washington Post by their own
admission what they're saying is they
have a top-secret source who provides
information to the CIA and the FBI who
was getting information from the Trump
campaign to develop this Russia story
that's a huge story I don't know why the
Department of Justice leaked that to the
Washington Post but that suggests also
that it doesn't even matter really who
the particular person is but this is a
new layer a new piece of information
that is definitely going to come out one
way or another and I can't imagine
they're going to be very successful at
keeping this new development secret well
and you often hear the argument that
that you know we can't provide more
information either to congressional
oversight committees or to the public
because it would jeopardize an
investigation it would expose a source
what-have-you and we just don't know
enough at this point to know whether
that's the case in this particular
instance but it is interesting
there have been leaks on both sides of
this there have been obvious government
leaks but there have been leaks I mean
part of the reason that we know more
about the nature of the original leak is
because there have been counter leaks so
it seems to me that if you upset about
leaks you got to be upset about leaks on
both sides all right I just really did
quite down the road how long do you
think it takes before Muller wraps up
his program it's it's hard to say I
would say six months I think it's going
to depend on how long it takes to
negotiate whether the president gets
subpoenaed whether the president goes in
and testifies but past the midterms if
he doesn't want it to go past the
midterms I don't think mother does not
yeah but I mean if they're going through
this negotiation once you get too close
to the midterms then you don't want to
do that either I think there's a lot
about the molar probe that is interested
in sort of saving face for the FBI and
it's being it's been difficult to do
that they don't have Russia collusion
the obstruction case is going to be
difficult to make they're moving on to
other things I don't know if it'll wrap
up soon